que nous l'appelions amouroux érotisme
que nous précisions amour physique ou
employons plus crûment le mot sexe les
choses de l'intime ont toujours revêtu
un aspect sulfureux ce sont les seuls en
ce cas des autres activités humaines
nous pouvons tout entendre tout accepter
il est un signe qui ne trompe point des
dix chefs d'oeuvre de l'érotisme réunis
par mille et une nuits en un coffret et
car la carte ou un auteur anonyme deux
siècles de rapprochement sensuelle voilà
un heureux programme le texte le plus
ancien et littérairement le plus
accompli véritable biscuits deux-sèvres
datant de 1777
nous le devons à vivant denon la nuit
merveilleuse est en quelque sorte la
version explicite de son chef-d'oeuvre
point de lendemain siècle des lumières
mais aussi du libertinage le 18e
s'enchante du sacrilège qui voit 16 beau
dire les gens d'église maupassant et
verlaine sont des habitués de l'enfer
des bibliothèques
l'un et l'autre ont usé de leur corps
autant que de leur plume célébrant l'un
par l'autre
quant à pierre louise petit maître
surdoué son manuel de civilité pour les
petites filles prétendre enseigner les
bonnes manières
je serais étonné qu'il ne vous fasse pas
sourire à tout le moins
[Musique]